[Music]
on April 26 1937 fascist forces bombed
the Basque village of Guernica in
northern Spain it was one of the worst
civilian casualties of the spanish civil
war waged between the democratic
republic the general Franco's fascist
contingent the Pablo Picasso the tragedy
sparked a frenzied period of work in
which he produced a massive anti-war
mural aptly titled Guernica the painting
is a powerful work of historical
documentation and political protest
but while the Casarez artistic
motivations are clear the symbolism of
the painting can be as confusing and
chaotic as war itself how can we make
sense of this overwhelming image and
what exactly makes it a masterpiece of
anti-war art the paintings monumental
canvas is disorienting from the start
rendered in the abstracted cubist style
Picasso pioneered cubism deliberately
emphasized the two dimensionality of the
canvas by flattening the objects being
painted this afforded viewers multiple
and often impossible perspectives on the
same object a technique considered
shocking even in Picasso's domestic
scenes but in this context the style
offers a profoundly overwhelming view of
violence destruction and casualties
multiple perspectives only compound the
horror on display sending the eyes
hurtling around the frame in a futile
hunt for peace on the far left a woman
holding her dead child releases a scream
her eyes sliding down her face
shape of tears and her head bending back
unnaturally to echo her babies there is
a statue of a soldier present below that
he is unable to defend the woman and
child instead his broken body lies in
pieces his arm clutching a splintered
sword in a signal of utmost defeat the
tip of his sword meets a woman's foot as
she attempts to flee the devastation but
her other leg appears rooted to the spot
locked in the corner of the canvas even
as she stretches to move it another
victim appears behind this lunging
figure falling helplessly as flames lick
around her she too is caught in her own
hopeless seat each of these figures
bordering the painting are horribly
trapped giving the work an acute sense
of claustrophobia and where you might
expect the canvases massive size to
counteract this feeling its scale only
highlights the nearly life-sized
atrocities and display some possible
relief comes from a lamp held tightly by
a ghostly woman reaching out her window
but is her lanterns hopeful glowed truly
lighting the scene or is it a jagged
light bulb thought to represent her
technologies of modern warfare which
illuminates her view of the chaos below
from the coffin-like confines of her
window her arm guides the viewer back
into the fray to perhaps the most
controversial symbols of all - ghostly
animals caught in the destruction does
the screaming horse embody the threat of
Franco's military nationalism or does
the spike running through its body
convey its victimhood does the white
bull represent Spain the country of
Matadors and a common theme in Picasso's
work or does it stand for the brutality
of war in this scene of strife these
animals raise more questions and answers
and additional elements hidden
throughout the frame offer even more
secrets for close observers at the top
of the canvas flashes a bird desperate
to escape the carnage and the abundance
of animals on display may hint at the
bombings date a market day which flooded
the streets with villagers animals and
other potential casualties like the
bombing of Guernica itself Picasso's
painting is Denys with destruction but
hidden beneath this supposed chaos are
carefully crafted scenes and symbols
carrying out the paintings multifaceted
attack on fascism decades after his
creation Jenica retains its power to
shock viewers an ignite debate and is
often referenced at anti-war gatherings
around the world hundreds of viewers
have grappled with his harsh imagery
shattering symbolism and complex
political messaging but even without a
close understanding of his complicated
subtext the casos work remains a searing
reminder of the true casualties of
violence interested in learning more
about art history check out this
playlist for the stories behind more
famous masterpieces
[Music]